I got some new tour dates to tell you
about uh we have Oakland California on
September 16th we've added a show there
Akron Ohio
October 7th we've added a show
Washington D.C on October 22nd we've
just added a show there also limited
tickets remaining from Milwaukee uh and
Las Vegas get all your tickets at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r uh if if if a show is sold out
don't go crazy and spend a ton of money
we'll come back through and uh and you
can get you a fair price ticket over
there
um again all tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r for the return of the Rat tour
thank you so much uh for just coming out
and being a part of my life new merch
for you merch heads out there we've got
some new shorts
that's right the Rat Life shorts and
blue salmon and sand
we've also got the new tie-dye be good
to yourself teas in aqua creamsicle and
indigo
get that in more only at
theovonstore.com
we want to thank Grand Cathedral cigars
in Tampa Florida for letting us host uh
the episode here at their
um beautiful lounge and
it's a cigar or
really a universe for cigaring
and um and doing that it's stunning it
is it is undeniably the nicest Cigar
Lounge that I've been in
now I've only been in probably 11 cigar
lounges
so that's the only part of it that I
want to be honest about but we are very
thankful for them in uh Tampa Florida at
2201 North Florida Avenue
today's guest is a 16 time
world champion uh there's nobody like
him I'll tell you that he's one of a
kind he has had quite a life
I mean the guy has been he's almost he
survived a plane crash a lightning
strike he's been through it all
we're grateful for his time today he's
one of the greatest entertainers of our
time today's guest is the Nature Boy
Rick
me
I sit and tell you my stories
and I am a song
yeah that's why I moved over to
Nashville a few years ago is that where
you live now yeah oh cool yeah that's a
great place save that tax money too yeah
no kidding and you can you can conceal
carry and carry a weapon over there oh
you can oh yeah I believe that will work
we're really cancer carry a weapon
though I mean
well heck in half your career somebody
always that's that was the funny thing
about wrestling somebody always showed
up with a web you know it's like Jesus
Christ you have no idea
you wouldn't believe some of the stories
I could tell you about Glenn's
yeah man I'm trying to think when I saw
my first gun
did y'all have guns in the house growing
up
yeah for my dad was an avid Hunter he
was yeah I grew up Minnesota so we
pheasant duck stuff like that oh yeah
dude you got not big game but shotguns
yeah and then I uh
I collected guns for years I had a a guy
that was a
policeman in Asheville North Carolina I
will mention his name
in the 70s that you know how these you
know these the guns that they recover
and raids and all that [__] right and he
would love to walk in the room pick out
what I wanted people might be people I
would just pay ridiculously low amount
of money like
um is an example they used to have the
state troopers used to carry that nickel
plated at 357 I mean yeah unbelievable
they can't find those guns anymore yeah
yeah the only the only gun I don't have
I I should have got it but I didn't
um
is I was going to buy a replica of the
Loan Survivor The Lone Ranger no the
Lone Survivor the rifle
oh I've never even seen it I don't think
oh yeah the one that that Bradley Cooper
Kerry remember yeah oh yeah who is it
who played Lone Survivor Wahlberg or
Cooper
yeah yeah they have right here in Tampa
I shot recently I shot
um I was in Nashville like shows at Kid
Rock's house have you ever met kids I
know real well yeah dude yeah and John
they went off with all five of the bars
now yeah yeah I'm trying to get the kid
to carry the drink he won't carry it for
you I haven't asked him yet I know him
real well
yeah his place is too much huh oh man
his place is unreal that he's got like
he built like a new it's almost like um
the capital of the south in a way or
something of the White House yeah yeah
yeah you roll up there you're like this
is unreal in a big arena I I thought it
was a little bit like a warehouse yeah
he's got a good iron uh Production
Studio in there all his collecting cars
and I mean two bars a church yeah 600
acres of prime land oh yeah he said he
can get married and divorced right there
legally on his property yeah
I said I think the bar probably helps
you get divorced I said I think that'll
lead to it yeah yeah he's not touring
right now he said I'm gonna let the
young kids or help Inspire them and help
them yeah
Rick thanks for for hanging out man
thank you for having me man I spent so
much of my childhood watching you man
and thank you thank you you know it was
uh
some people watched WWF right yeah and
that was fine that was easy yeah but I
when I was a kid if you stayed up and if
you watched NWA right that's who knew
about like those that's when you could
tell if people were rich or not yeah
that's what I felt like like poor kids
always knew about all the NWA guys yeah
where are you from I'm from uh Covington
Louisiana okay so just like a small town
outside of New Orleans Mid-South yeah
dude Terry Funk just
um oh just God there was so much awesome
wrestling back then jyd oh dude
yeah what was he like in person good guy
yeah yeah you had way too early but that
was the rock and roll Express for their
Midnight Express Bill Watts yeah
you know a lot of we've lost a lot of
them unfortunately Devon Eric's oh all
gone except for Kevin
and that's that I mean yeah that whole
family just tragedy three suicides I
think in the family did you go to any of
those funerals what about the funerals
over the years have they I went to three
of them um
well let's see the oldest son you know
got electrocuted that when his dad first
started out there in Buffalo New York
yeah when he was a kid had a trailer
and he was not he never wrestled or
anything but he's got electrocuted
a little hot wire and a damn uh trailer
park and then uh Carey
David
you know I had some kind of a
obviously illegal substance it was a
I can't remember what they're called but
it was probably I hope it was cocaine no
no it's a muscle relaxer oh he choked to
death he couldn't regurgitate they call
him um
Somas Somas dude oh yeah yeah I took him
he loaded up on Somas and he got sick
after eating Korean barbecue and all
that which we all do in Japan and uh he
died right there in his own room same
thing happened to Miss Elizabeth
really yeah she couldn't regurgitate
because she was taking it was almost
like that I've never understood that but
that that high from the song there's
nothing that I want to entertain ever
yeah a buddy of mine gave me two Somas
once and I and I was he wanted me to
drive us somewhere yeah so he was not as
he's not the smartest guy and I drove us
in onto a street that didn't even exist
right when it did I'm sure I've never
tried one but man I've
I Hope they've been I can name of three
or four guys that have died
you know because they just can't
regurgitate and wake up in the middle of
the night and that the soulmates relax
your muscles are bad you can't yeah yeah
I mean it's ten times impact about
Valium
yeah man some of those medicines are
just too powerful yeah did um did you go
to some funerals of the year what was
what was like a wild funeral what was
one that really hit you man was there I
mean obviously funerals are just
heartbreaking
oh probably the hardest for me um
in the last five years but well first of
all dusty religious
Dusty and Piper were really difficult
yeah and then Harley Race
that was really difficult but um yeah
Dustin just a shot I mean it must have
been heartbreaking the WWE
they they the funeral for Dusty with his
with his will handles I think we're
seeing they had it here in Tampa
obviously and uh there were probably 2
000 people trying to get in
but the WWE had full security and um
the boys spoke so elegantly of their dad
um Cody was wrestling now but they both
wrestle but I called you with WWE
was telling a story and he you know I he
didn't neither one broke down real bad
I'll break down what I think about it
but he said
he asked his mom one time he said how
come it's only
just pictures of dad in the house and no
other wrestlers and his mother replied
why would you have a picture of any
other wrestler when you're married to
Elvis
um
well he was was he a good husband what
kind of guy was he great guy wow he was
so lovable most innovative
you know one of the most Innovative
right there type we're tied withins
and Innovative with ideas and creativity
and
he was so fun to like there's wrestlers
that are entertaining to watch because
of their physical Acumen there's
wrestlers that are entertaining to watch
because of the moves they do yeah
Dusty had that like I loved when he
would go against the ropes and kind of
put on this like like almost feminine
Wilds kind of thing you know and like he
was just a con um you know I wrestle him
probably
a thousand hour Broadway we could
wrestle for an hour wow yeah don't let
his weight it wasn't it was deceiving is
to the fact that he could he he was in
good condition it's hard to wrestle an
hour yeah oh yeah dude oh I can't even
make love for 11 minutes yeah
to be honest with you so
so yeah you put me against another man I
can't do an hour bro you know no matter
what city we're in I better keep you
overnight in Tampa Tonight brother
I get some people who can help you out
with that
I don't know
what about me he said hey we both
started at the same time I can't help it
if you can't keep up
that doesn't fly with the chicks these
days no these days yeah all these chicks
want to you know everybody wants to get
off and it's just too much man
I missed the old days when a woman was
as happy you showed up
foreign
I can't yeah man well I always had to
take you know I always had so I was
always so nervous I've always been
nervous kind of nervous my whole life
and I've always had to get those gas
station pills those wiener pills you
know
and a lot of the series they came out
with they never even tested I don't
think on humans or whatever I think a
lot of them were animal tested yeah
which I respect but it's a little
different you know three blocks from
here at the age illumination clinic
right I get four shots a week though
really I think if I have to be there
they shoot you up oh yeah oh wow it's
amazing what you can do to yourself
these days if you got the money make
sure they shoot you right in your weiner
yeah right there
it takes 25 years office
yeah cause look I would get these I'd
get the gas station pills and then make
my legs Sweat Right
so I could have heck but I could barely
stay on the bed that was the problem
I mean it would be like the lady like
she like did you get off I'm like no but
I think my thighs did I mean I would
they make your legs sweat so bad some of
them they made them in India yeah and uh
I mean those shook my nervous system but
um yeah I've always needed the pills man
I think I used to I used a lot of
steroids when I was young and I don't
know if that had enough I don't know who
know who knows you know it could be that
I'm in my head a lot but
um yeah [__] I've always interviewed too
and I have to admit in my youth oh yeah
dude I took them dude I once I'll tell
you and small testicles you get small
yeah
nobody explains the downside
oh man you could spend four minutes
looking for one of your nuts
exactly we got the medicine over here to
make them grow back
it's called ACG how big do they get uh I
don't know everybody everybody's got a
different opinion
oh I remember when I got so small one
well I think when I was a senior in high
school like trying to find the last two
pieces
in a pillow case man it was it was uh it
got pretty bad there
yeah I remember we used to use test 200
I think was what we used or something
doing it on the ground test yeah God
that [__] was fun yeah my God I would
[__] choke out my own stepmother yeah
and I don't even have one you know I
never I never experienced that and I
don't never gave me I guess I didn't
take enough of it but I didn't have that
what they call road rage
I mean I the things that upset me over
the years but it wasn't
as a result of being a steroids you know
yeah but I think you had enough you had
enough energy in you yeah I've always
been eyeing it yeah what a blessing huh
yeah people have always assumed that I
snorted cocaine and all that
the only jug I've ever taken
um but it was prescriptions and Xanax
really no cocaine
uh I just smoke weed when I'm young
you're not smoking now
that I'm involved in a world of cannabis
but um
I think that's one of the reasons I'm
still here because that that the up and
down of cocaine and then the guys would
take the uppers
in the morning or not just our guys but
athletes period yeah it's a game when
you're competing stay up and then go
down stay up especially you know when
you're International when you're
traveling internationally you know like
going to Japan twice a month or going to
Australia twice a month like I was doing
it in the 80s it was crazy yeah
yeah and once you get used this is the
tough thing about use in performance and
answers I think once you get used to
getting something to help you get up or
to get down it's hard not to want to use
it again yeah and then you need the
opposite of it yeah so that's where it
gets really tricky well when I almost
died in 17.
I mean I literally you know do you know
the story I mean I know a lot of surgery
almost died so which one are we talking
about though 2017 okay my intestine oh
when you had the uh some when you had
the test and rupture right of a septic
respiratory heart failure total kidney
failure pneumonia Centric being the
worst part right they had it and I was
in a coma for 13 days
so um
when all that and of course I had a
stoma the bag
had that for a year but at the end of
the day when I finally realized and I
had no memory for six months going
backwards forward from the time I woke
up of course I recognized everybody but
I couldn't remember anything
I didn't remember going to the hospital
wow um so but when I finally started
taking a toll of myself like I thought
[__] I am really a [__] I'm a
nightmare to cosmetic [__] nightmare
I look like [__] my my and I
um
so what do you mean a cosmetic nightmare
I mean I've got a scar from here to here
uh I lost 41 pounds I was
stoma I'll show you some pictures later
on it was bad so that changed everything
yeah and my testosterone column you know
something I always took pride in right
and we all do we get it done it's good
blood work is a necessity of life my
testosterone column was 12. that can
kill you alone but doctors don't want to
play the word testosterone is like
nor like you know doctors wanted
I mean you can there are ways to find
out the levels that you should be at but
I was down to 12. wow so I called the
doctors will be that's that's too old
but I don't want to prescribe it 12 what
it's 12 12 sounds like yeah it's
supposed to be 400 of my age yeah 12
left dude yeah I came into the Thousand
now oh okay but I have to run by the gas
station every week
the 400 my age don't work I hate the
Thousand I gotta have open check oh yeah
brother this is a thousand to a high for
you nope perfect
yeah so you were out of commitment what
was it like to be in a comment I always
wanted to be in a coma I just dreamed
I just dreamed and now you wake up my I
like I dropped my daughter I got married
and
I went back and all of my stuff in
wrestling it's funny I got so high with
Mike one night Mike Tyson is that ever
talk about Mike Tyson yeah so high we're
Partners in the Cannabis business got so
high with Mike one night at The Hamptons
that I went to call the um
a cannabis coma right
I mean I actually thought I died
I said I said to myself
and they they brought me back to my room
and I lived there and I thought I mean I
wasn't aware of anything I kept asking
people to touch
you know like you do when you think it
better hurt and people were squeezing my
hand but I'd be talking to him and they
wouldn't talk back to me and I was like
you know on the delay process right yeah
and I said to myself did I die
if I just died because I feel like I did
when I was in my coma but I can think I
don't think I could think when I was in
my colon I mean that's the way I was
talking to myself wow so and all of a
sudden
I mean everything possible work like the
room finally at three o'clock in the
morning I kind of sat up like Linda
Blair went
I'm alive I'm back yeah
I called someone on the phone and say is
this really you okay
that was just a television that was a
television timeout oh my God
that's all that was oh I said I take my
clothes off at the dining room table or
anything but let me know what I've done
wrong all I could think of what I
possibly could have done wrong yeah oh
yeah man I remember I remember
just being too I'll just yeah there's
something about that level of weed now
it gets you too high oh well I just
haven't done enough on my my practice up
every time I knew I'm going to see Mike
yeah you got to work your way up to it
yeah
I'm about a three or four hit guys
I just said I'm gonna smoke as much as
you right now brother
dude that weed comes off the top bro oh
man yeah that's it make it highlight
dude I remember getting so high one
night I was trying to sneak up on a
mirror
for like probably two hours
that's good and I'll tell you this dude
I got pretty [__] close man
sneaking up on the mirror oh I think if
it had been a leap year I could have
done it I should have brought some Ric
Flair drip for you man oh I'll get some
okay I'll get some I'm glad I got this
man you brought me this okay I mean this
alone is pretty epic yeah you know it's
great you are an energy you are you are
like an original human energy drink so I
am yeah so to have one yeah makes
perfect sense
have you been in an accident have you
been damaged up check your body is
something broken is something missing
that's the you're like whoa jeepers
no wonder I'm late to work I don't have
a limb
well Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm
if someone has done you wrong
well what are you gonna do
being fair is
very important to me Morgan and Morgan
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting to get
you full and fair compensation
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as as washing your thighs
baby with warm water and good soap Free
Soap
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan
that's right could be a car accident
could have been something that happened
at work
fairness is important
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win for more information go
to forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone that's for the people.com slash
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement this episode is brought to
you by betterhelp
that's right
I've gotten therapy I've gotten better
help
um you know I've had times where I
wasn't seeing
the world as comfortably as I should be
you know and it wasn't just a little
thing it wasn't just something that I
knew would pass it was something that
that was building and gaining momentum
inside of me and it kind of scared me
you know if you're struggling if there's
something that's off it's
I mean we're humans
we have a voice and we need to use that
and we need to get feedback from someone
who knows what they're talking about
Better Health can help set you up with a
licensed professional
that's right it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time there's no charge
and I want to iterate that if if you are
going to a therapist and it's super
comfortable and easy
but nothing's changing then that might
not be the best scenario
you can always try a new one here or
there you can go back to the first one
if you want
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's right that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp
you know one thing Rick that I noticed
that you did that you always did really
exceptionally which kept me super
entertained was
your ability to
play defense actively right like even if
you were being the victim in the fight
yeah you were always like asking for
Mercy there was always if you got hit
you always win over your own legs yeah
it was like it was as much fun to watch
you like being defeated as it was to
watch you
winning and for some reason sometimes it
was almost I'm better getting beat you
were good at it you were really good at
it weren't you and then I just lie the
next day on TV and if you don't forget
about it that didn't happen to me when
you were begging nobody did it like yeah
it was it was just there was especially
with the hair red oh blood flying
everywhere but there was something about
it that because a lot of guys they would
just be getting beat in that moment yeah
but you were always
actively demanding the attention
sometimes I wouldn't even know who was
hitting you because I was watching you
and that's really interesting a lot of
times you're watching the beater you
know
yeah I could take an ass kicking I was
really good at that how did that energy
start you think I just have I've had it
my whole life brother I was add before
add was about oh yeah I'm still looking
out the window in fourth grading
Richard we have your attention please uh
social studies one-on-one
I spent 13 years in high school let me
tell you I still haven't passed English
or Latin there's only four years of it
now I was there five I mean
I didn't go to 12th grade I went to 13th
grade
foreign
did you go to prom do you remember going
did you go to high school prom oh yeah
yeah who was it yeah uh well here's the
funny thing I I this is a great story
I've never told us before so I
hitchhiked my parents from Minneapolis
I'm very conservative I wasn't
private school in Wisconsin I got in
trouble it was either
private school nothing bad yeah the
Hadley Center where'd you go what was it
called I went to Wayland Academy in
Beaver Dam
Prep School very expensive with either
that or a reform school because I got in
some trouble
um
trying to buy liquor underage nothing
serious but it was enough to get me in
trouble and then riding my scooter
around Lake Calhoun so I got there so I
made all these friends and you know
there's no cell phones back in the 60s
and all that so now I have a whole new
group of friends and they're all
from wealthy families and they go to
everybody's going to spring break I said
what's spring break I said we're all
going to Florida
so I went home and I said to my mom and
dad a second I go visit my friend Bruce
in Chicago
and they said yeah they gave me 200
bucks and took me the train station and
they drove off when I walked all the
train station and hitchhiked all the way
to Fort Lauderdale wow it was the
greatest I did have two years in a row
so you go right up to the interstate and
put your thumb brother I'm telling you
out I mean I'm walking through making
Coney land man I mean that was some
strange [__] for a guy from Minneapolis
walking through making Georgia brother
yeah the hell is looking different than
Minneapolis so anyway then I got picked
up by these college girls
I went right in so my first night there
I'm in I'm in Arby's right and with my
friend in this chick was working on
Arby's and she goes um
Wisconsin leather jacket on a no shirt
and I didn't like trying to be cool and
uh she goes where'd you go to school I
said the University of Wisconsin she
said cool she said you want to go have
drinks afterwards I said what time you
get off she said 10 o'clock
and so I ended up staying with her and
her mom wow on top of her but my mom on
top of which one both
but I invited the one I got invited the
one to uh uh what was their 10 days I
mean dude in 10 days you got to meet the
whole family right exactly
um but I ended up inviting her to to
prom you know but not even thinking and
so I get a letter from her at school and
she said um my mom is flying me to
Madison are you going to pick me up
particularly the prom and I had a
girlfriend in high school oh boy that
was bad so I did another question and I
made a mistake so
Gwen Worthen was her name oh like when
where are you now
when were the forgive me and so she did
she she didn't fly in then
you told your girlfriend you couldn't
take her yeah
yeah all right so was it strange because
I I I similarly brought a girl to I
didn't really have like that kind of
relationship in high school right
because they gave us what what they
called Saturday night but this is a
great [__] they gave us what's called
soulish right so what is it called
10 minutes to go hide behind a tree who
did the parents no the school did oh
really they have dances and all that
right at 10 o'clock you got 10 minutes
ago I'd be in the tree and then back
with a cool at school back to the
dormitories the dormitories weren't cold
right but we all had binoculars and [__]
you know in telescope looking at the
chicken you get a lot of intake
he had the Intel the hell
so
uh so they gave you 10 minutes after the
prom and after the dancing after after
every Saturday night they called them
soj okay you guys are gonna have 10
minutes
right I mean come on yeah but you could
try I know I did
just as I got that first hook I called
young with the whistle whoa whoa
it's like a military drill Everybody Run
you have 10 seconds to return it over
all right well turn the goddamn dogs
loose
I just wear a big sweater nobody will
know
God that was fun so you had it you
weren't you were unsuccessful with uh
staying committed in a relationship from
the beginning oh yeah I've had problems
with that with relationships I've been
married four times wow but that a lot of
that is in respect to my travel God you
know
you you being a fan you probably didn't
realize I wrestled an average of 400
days a year 400 times yeah because twice
on Saturday twice on Sunday for 10 years
Michael how can you wrestle foreign
you graduated but there's only 365 days
right I said I know but I wrestled twice
on Saturday twice on Sunday
man I did that for 10 years you cannot
I'm never home how do you how do you
stay married some women just can't live
like that and I don't blame them yeah of
course not yeah my first wife just said
this is cool and I have two kids by her
we get along with this day we never had
an argument she just said this is not
what I signed up for yeah I said I'll
buy you a bigger house because I don't
care I don't I've been spending my life
alone
because once you get on the road and if
you're successful as you know yeah
it's fun yeah yeah you know and why go
home
if you have a day off and you're like in
Los Angeles you have one day off are you
gonna go all the way back that's right
on Carolina or you can stay in L.A
you're gonna stay in L.A New York I mean
yeah I mean you find your old family how
many guys do you feel like had kind of
illegitimate children out there and oh I
don't know do you think it started to
happen
I think I'm I'm sure it has happened but
I mean that happens and that happens
with any traveling people that travel
yeah it's gonna happen because I've
never experienced that myself
but you know some of these girls not in
the old days they want to get pregnant
oh yeah if you had money they wanted to
get pregnant can you guess what hello
you know that's why all this stuff is so
sophisticated now with DNA and all that
that stuff it wasn't around back when I
was a your age now but yeah you had to
hold the baby up next to the man yeah
it's crazy
but I know I never experienced that I
don't know but I think you know with
volume back it that kids can't all fall
back on wrestlers because right yeah
well yeah yeah well it's happened I mean
the football players that travel the
basketball play the travel baseball
players are never home I mean you have
pilots and flight attendants come on
they're just yeah I mean they just in
the old days that was they were the most
fun the flight attendants were the most
fun can we have matches we have tickets
at the match yesterday yes are you
saying that oh okay I'm not supposed to
tell you but that
they still are some of them but it's
just an attitude thing now but some of
them now they're hot but then they're
they're like
men
well it's just you know they're just
kind of like you think it's a woman and
then they turn and when they say you
know and they're like I'm a man you know
you're like oh dang I have I have an
experienced that but I've experienced it
work they just don't want to do any more
than they have to yeah in the old days I
think that they were they were they
would go above and beyond above and
beyond because but but but normal yeah
that makes sense yeah things have
changed a lot with that and
you know you you just you can't you
can't you got to be very careful what
you say to a woman and all oh yeah I
mean okay you couldn't exist nowadays no
me no I'm kidding got it
I used to walk around all the flight
attendants doing the Sweet and Low joke
you know I'll show it to you later on
you know what's your difference between
sugar and sweet little shoulder later on
no you couldn't know you could never do
that with a planet then and now good
Lord but did women get offended back
then by it or they kind of liked
flirting or well are you kidding yeah
you I mean but but
you know now it's like any kind of
travel today I I mean I dread that's why
I fly private a lot if I if I can if I
if it's within if it's practical yeah I
understood
um because people in general they put
computers on put earplugs on you got no
one to talk to people don't drink and
the old days people would drink on the
plane Oh yeah talk to each other and
walk around and now everything is such a
stringent I mean everything is a rule
yes you know remember the old we used to
sit in the old cabinets on the higher
end the 747s
tell stories laugh and they're big trays
of food I mean that all that stuff on on
our domestic Airlines has gone yeah now
the foreign Airlines still let that
stuff go on oh yeah we've shut down
everything Singapore Airlines you would
never get off the plane yeah
you can get a massage yeah everything
they had somebody come on polish my feet
on there did they yeah I never had I
don't even know they needed polish
anything you want they'll do it all dude
yeah they'll [__] cut your I mean
they'll cut the hair on the back of your
legs but on ongoing uh
Dom Perignon I mean they just they never
stop serving you yeah it's great but
domestically we've just gotten so
conservative and
this is different everything is a rule
that's a great statement everything's a
rule now it's like don't attack the
pilots don't smoke in the bathroom well
I understand that but I mean it's just
you know I understand the pilot thing
but it's like you know if you're I'll
give you an example so I fly I've got
like I've got four million miles with uh
Delta and I had to when you add up all
my mileage over the years uh if 70
million I'm sure no I probably had 15
million miles
between Northwest and which went
bankrupt Eastern went bankrupt U.S error
well I mean they've all
you know have gone upside down American
United well they're they're still going
and Delta of course is my favorite
choice I like Delta too yeah but um we
used to be able to socialize and all
that now you know when the cap like when
the thing goes on and they go here's
what makes me mad and I'm sure you felt
it you know when the captain goes okay
ladies and gentlemen we're getting ready
to approach that means you're right at
ten thousand feet I know this for a fact
you're still
45 to 50 minutes from touching down
to play in his assembly man grab a cup
of coffee no we have uh we've closed the
galley yeah man the flight We're Not
Gonna land for 50 minutes oh that's I'm
sorry I think Well ma'am I said um can I
have a built beer she said don't we
close it up I said is that your rule or
the flight Rule I said are you I mean
I've had women like a girl go are you
harassing me I said no I've seen it for
a beer
excuse me you know or they'll go oh yeah
please Mr Floor what would you like yeah
you can have a picture can we do a sign
something for my son it's a or b yeah
and someone and I would say it's like 80
or 60 40 good but the 40 can just you
know and then and then like I had that
surgery right that bag and broke a
couple times yeah it smells bad right I
had to stay in three hours in the
bathroom
the woman's knocking what are you doing
oh oh you really don't want me to know
but don't knock on the door again I mean
that you can't yeah it's horrible wow
because it's a year it's SOB yeah that's
your intestine it's so it's attached to
intestine so it's dookie yeah yeah it's
terrible
it it's terrible damn yeah I would not
wish that anybody ever yeah I mean I've
stepped in [__] before and that's yeah
that's if I was bringing my own [__]
outside of me oh my God I would be
bummed out my wife actually had to learn
how to clean it why why we hired
full-time help right yeah
it got me where like on the weekend and
then like a weekend warrior it's like
like being in a rest home the regular
staff has gone and the people working on
the weekends I don't want to be there
anyway they're second string third
straight yeah you're talking so then she
finally went August
and learn how to do it herself but it's
nasty man yeah and and you have to
re-watch what you eat because different
things trigger it that makes sense was
it kind of cool to eat some things and
see them come out in the bag
I know the bank wasn't clear no it
wasn't that they didn't make clear bags
damn you got to get that clear one huh
I'm saying that'd be crazy I'm laughing
right now it wasn't funny then oh yeah
no it's crazy my sister was born with a
rare liver disease and uh so she needed
a transplant her whole lives when we
were kids and so she had to have a bag a
lot and so there was always
um we were always dealing with bile or
some type of thing around the house you
know it's terrible I I feel a lot of I
feel bad at making light of it but no
we're joking no I was just saying some
of the the things that you go through
with that condition it's and it takes
really patient of people
does that make sense oh yeah that really
care for you that to be around you who
nurses that's one thing I would love to
marry a nurse I think one day because
this the the ability to have that job is
really a god-game gift I think
let me tell you this I I had right after
this right
um I had to have four heart surgeries in
uh seven weeks okay but by the time
by the second two they were walking me
in
in the same room and the same nurses and
the girl brought it up what do you call
those things that a player would she
would play my space
yeah and she goes she she goes to me I
swear to God you couldn't make it up
right so they're eight dollars
government and she put a washcloth on
top of my uh groin and she said I won't
like but she space not looking like this
I hope she meant the other nurses
these days you don't know who's trying
to leave oh my god wow or take a picture
social media Ric flurry and all that
[__]
yeah
look at this little dealing
foreign
you guys sign the release and they
couldn't make water release
they all started laughing I go I go she
goes we don't do that here I said ma'am
I'm just kidding
let us
we don't cyber leaves I'm just kidding
please
dude
oh yeah good penis yeah some people
might as well so yeah girls girls use
that word more than guys do now it's
different it is oh girls will send
messages girls will be like come and
[__] me you creep yeah I'm like Jesus
well all right I haven't got one of
those lately
number
what uh what state had the best women do
you think
Florida
here or uh because Florida has a lot of
criminals built into it there's
something about that pirate because
remember Pirates started this place
there's Spanish people can dance they
can hide treasure yeah it's it's a great
place to live but you know the
difference between Miami and Tampa like
night and day yeah
um Tampa just this is great but Texas
beautiful women there oh yeah there's
beautiful women everywhere but you it
just seems like they're an abundance of
them Tampa
the government plenty of all the
colleges here you know got Tampa
University then you have South Florida
Hooters UCF Where She Went I mean and
then you've got Florida Florida State I
mean there's a bar over here called amso
that during the football season when the
alumni and its Insanity what's it called
American Social okay am so yeah and they
that's over here on the water you know
with the odds outside and everything and
it I would say it's probably
um
probably 14 or 15 000 square feet it's
big yeah and they can house it but man
for the they have like 30 TVs for these
college games and that if you're ever in
town it's a Vibe huh it's a Vibe and a
half and there are women everywhere God
God I wish I was 35 just one day
what would you do you think
Oh I thought about that a lot I don't
know man
but just give me an idea 35 on a
Saturday
in in American Social a lot I could do a
lot of damage
30 even more
that five years
who did you guys after the matches did
was there like group shot how did it all
was there like a big group shower oh it
was a big group shower like for that
like did you guys was it like a football
team that after the after the night
everybody was it like a big no the guy's
shower I mean to get their matches are
gone yeah yeah
and when you guys used to drive I mean
one thing that's always fascinating
about wrestlers I'm friends with The Miz
right he's a wrestler oh yeah and he's a
great kid he is a great guy how do you
know him he's a great guy we've known
each other for almost 15 years now oh
he's a great kid yeah he's a guy that
really cares for the businessman and
they [__] on him when he started they
gave him a tough time they gave him a
tough time that's a [__] and that
you know that that's the guy is a bully
I got no time for that but yeah he's a
wonderful kid yeah and he's made the
most of it and I I'll go and tell you
the truth
whatever they hand him he goes
he doesn't complain if he does I'm not
aware of it and so damn respectful he's
a great kid yeah
yeah I met him years ago with his Dad he
was always a hard worker yeah and just
extremely cares that he always had that
energy that was uh he always had this
Charisma that was a little bit beyond
him as a person he's a Cleveland guy
yeah Ziggler oh his Dolph yeah he had a
dolphin comedian too you know right yeah
I know that he's I know that he's done
some comedy and I communicate sometimes
on social media yeah but um he's a great
kid The Miz and I've been friends for a
long time and uh I've always admired his
ability to roll with the punches yeah
what was it like whenever you did they
did your storyline ever get like where
you were like I know you had the like
those [__] off years where you didn't
love it and um yeah
worse
it must have been hard huh well I was
like you know he ought to say it out of
mind it didn't work
he kept trying to lose me like what do
you mean out of sight out of mind I mean
if he thought if he could take real TV
and bury me that that he forgot he
forgot where I'd been for 20 years or 25
years before I met him yeah yeah you
don't lose 25 years of being a man
and then all of a sudden have some [__]
try and put you in the back of the pack
yeah
yeah I don't even think you couldn't
either you know he beat my brains out
though that that was a big
self-confidence
a big time a big time
loss of self-confidence period in my
life yeah
yeah
I guess you don't have as much control
over how not relevant you stay but how
much visual how much
attention they give you I mean it's kind
of interesting the way you guys business
is set up right it's like you're the
performer you're the athlete you're the
competitor but then there's also this
business side that kind of gets to
politics right
was it like that early on did it change
it wasn't like that early on when I got
into business you were either good they
were bad
men if you were bad and they don't like
it they beat you up really right beats
you up right in the ring if they could
yeah
yeah now it's so political it's off
Jesus it's a business more yeah usually
when I when when when you enjoyed it the
most when I enjoyed it the most is when
you were there because you were that
much better
than the next guy
or the woman with it now it's
you can be better than anybody but it's
all
it's it's it it's sad
but you either accept it or you don't
be part of it I'd rather be part of it
and accept it and I don't talk about it
and I'm not talking about any
individuals I'm just addressing
the reality of our business now I mean
yeah it's it's very political yeah where
football and all that it's political but
you're not going to put Aaron Rodgers
down you're not going to put down XYZ
you guy guy well just whatever I'm using
you there in this example yeah because
he says something smart yeah you're
gonna play to win
right and if somebody says something
smart it's almost with you guys it's it
almost would behoove them to use that as
the well yeah but they have these
writers that come in that I've never
wrestled writers are unreal I mean they
they come and they go a turnover and how
do you ever get to learn the business
if it took me if it took me 12 years
let's say I I started in 72. I didn't
figure this [__] out really till 83.
so how long is that 10 years nine years
yeah yeah it took me nine years to
figure it out and every time I thought I
had an I had it
something else popped up yeah but then I
once I got it I didn't let it go
but then people want to take it from me
always too old about it it's not ready
it doesn't look the same but uh
80s heels don't drive hurt at all yeah
and here I'm sitting here with here
sitting here with you today and where
are they yeah I don't know they're
driving between towns yeah
what was it like when you guys would hit
the road was that a lot of fun did you
guys enjoy thousand miles a week man
minimum yeah it was fun and it was
mostly the southeast you guys were in
huh well I was in Charlotte I'm probably
the only wrestler alive
uh even Hulk had to move out of Florida
he moved to Stanford a while he's doing
that but Hulk and I are probably only
two guys
that during that during the course of
our career
in our Heyday that uh never left home I
never left Charlotte they wanted me to
go to Atlanta they wanted me to go
the Florida I mean I wish I had come
down here only because of the day state
tax issue tax savings yeah but once I
found it when I was there it was when I
got to Charlotte with me and Richard
Petty the highest building was 10
stories Brown Bay I mean I've seen that
Tom grow
and why would I leave that to come
anywhere right yeah especially if it's
your home yeah if it's a city you feel
like that's your home well I moved there
when I was 23 and I grew with the city
yeah did all your wives you met them all
in Charlotte
yeah wow no
um my first wife I met Minneapolis she's
from Minneapolis oh yeah she lived in
Charlotte now because of my
grandchildren
yeah
never had a crossword just
great story so we used to stay at the
Raleigh Hilton and there was a bar
called the Hilton underground right
so this guy walked towards me and says
goddamn I was talking about 10 girls
that was packed
because I used to always say on TV
but I used to go wherever whatever hotel
we were going to be in there say 18 to
28 no boyfriends no husbands yeah
comes through the Nature Boy
or
what'd your wife think of that well same
thing you'd love about me not one of my
wedding rings why are you wear a wedding
as a guy that's not my gimmick honey
please
why why are you tell him what we were
saying I said they give us a deal on the
hotel room what do you think I mean do
you have to think anybody showed it up
boring I'm going to put into place is
packed
the guy goes to me
get a guy get lasers I look at that guy
get laid but you can get I'll get you
later on here no staircase let me buy
you a drink he was my wife's private eye
I can call him right now
she run the Speedway Club in Charlotte
though
oh hello
they're laying a little joke girl they
want to ride with you it's like be my El
Dorado
man you're so dude you like hooking your
buddies up yeah yeah it was hard getting
back to Tokyo was impossible to get laid
but really yeah so in Tokyo it was hard
to get him it was hard to get a little
person laid Yeah but uh hang uh Cowboy
Lang had a pretty good hang on them so I
could sell that for the game yeah yeah
odd boy I'd hate I mean it'd be so hard
I mean that would be
just you know
that's like a damn kettlebell
something like that
I mean if you even have half a pound of
of wiener on them on a little person
that's [__] yeah it looks a lot
bigger
and it's passive if you put the right
makeup on the sides of it dude because
I'll put makeup on mine I'm making a
look you know you wanted the light hit
it the right way
lighting's everything
when was the first time you got laid you
remember it uh 15 wow yeah
it was um
14 I mean 14 or 15. I was I had just got
my WSI and I was a what is a WSI water
safety instructor for a lifeguard about
uh
I got I got my lifeguarding thing I must
put anything hey I think I just turned
15. so
um I got my WSS I could be a lifeguard
at the my parents lived in the Colony
Apartments while they're waiting for a
new home to reveal for two years so I
this summertime job I clean the pool
lifeguard good swimming instructions
talk to the mothers yeah yeah
God boy The Traveler the little the
lonely mothers or their husbands on the
road like
to be a little Nature Boy
foreign
I want to let you know that uh gray
block Pizza you know they uh were the
first sponsor of this podcast and
um the owner
moved on
he he he folded up
his Doe
and uh and he moved to Oregon and he
started a business called blue cube
baths and they are ice plunges they are
cold plunges and man they just put you
God they just put you right back into
the cradle of civilization baby they
make you feel alive son
that make up oh
don't make a dang Eagle land on your
tongue just the virility you feel being
in there
they're really really wonderful blue
cube
baths.com you can check them out I was
very fortunate to receive one as a gift
from them and I just can't recommend
them enough and I just wanted to let you
know how they associate uh to the
podcast and if you're interested in in
an ice bath or in a cold plunge blue
cube baths is where to go
you know it was a fun job so you met a
lady there flight attendants I met oh
got a flight attendants there was
everything Jesus to this day I'm not a
beta because like I I was I was seeing
this girl that was a flight attendant
for Northwest Airlines who was dating
the head of the bed out the beta house
at the University of Minnesota so when
they rushed me at like five years later
the guy never he never got over it
yeah he was jealous
I guess I was 15 and she was what 23.
yeah
dang that's a win brother I used to be
sitting there I'd talk to her mom and
dad in the apartment and she would say
Rick come to the door I want to come up
to the stairways I can show you
something and she I'd walk over to the
store and she would stand in her
completely naked in high heels wow going
like this
oh yeah yeah okay
my God boy
and tits was just so nice back then
weren't they everything my god I've
never seen it like that in my entire
life even in the magazines it looks
different yeah nothing like a real tit
yeah you're an adult woman my God
I blew Coral or a car which took me 10
hours you what I blew Coral to her car
which is that old-fashion deal or it's
10 hours sweating like a snow [__] 120
degrees that's how much I like that
stuff she had a 442 and that's the first
one we ever made love to yeah no no no
with the person I made love to was I
didn't know how to make love oh yeah
yeah I was like you know who knows
but the the the the validity of the of
the fact is I I could recover in six
seconds so wow
okay let me just okay I'm ready wow
really oh my God like a human score gun
I never had that I would get I would get
counted out of the ring all the time
yeah
I mean I would get yeah
God and there's nothing sadder I'll tell
you this from somebody you don't have
this experience but I'll tell you
there's nothing sadder when a girl's
like you want to go again you're like I
want to yeah but we're not yeah and then
you have to sit there and do something
or you gotta [__] go get a lemonade
or something yeah
I haven't experienced that but I haven't
yeah I have but in that situation I just
go like I'm tired
the worst part is I never say I can't I
never in that free you never tell a
woman the truth no Jesus then you start
telling her the truth then you got to be
honest with yourself and that's hard to
do with women oh [__] they can put the
hottest light on me and ask me a
thousand times and and I and I am guilty
of doing it but there's still a little
admit it wow I told the judge five times
judge I did not do that we have to we
have you on film that's not me it looks
just like you why it's not me
the fifth
man I'm gonna remember that
um
boy you're in trouble yeah holy cow but
living with women women like that game
they wanted they wanted they want you to
they want to be they want to be as
clever as we are but they're not
so women like the game huh you gotta
remember that oh sure they do yeah
that's a lot I'm gonna tell you
something right now women love Cowboys
ladies love outlaws like little baby in
love with stray dogs you know that yeah
yeah for every good woman there's two
Outlaws
for every Outlaws is 20 women yeah
even if there's your blanks
they make the noise
hey
oh man yeah that's crazy
God yeah dude there's been some times on
the road it's like yeah there's
sometimes you like there I think there
could be a woman that could come up to
me right now and be like do you remember
this and I'm like I have no idea about
that yeah first of all a lot of them
don't look the same I just I have no
idea we're talking about
to be with me in 1982 I said whoo
you know why I mean Hello someone move
her out of line she's blocking traffic
here she's claiming she knows it's
impossible
boy we I think I've got a cold
have you had some ladies that came back
hell yeah my God that happens at least
once a month differences around the
country remember me no
and now how old are they uh well I'm 74.
some are oh my God
and I probably
everybody your age is dead
and some of these chicks might as well
there's no way that you and I now and
the Mariana Westshore not a chance dude
mistaken identity you got the wrong guy
my name is Fred Phillips not Ric Flair
did you watch my biography
was it you worked I know you worked on
the road who do you who was fun to
travel with on the road like when you
guys were just in the car cruise and who
was it oh me aren't Italian Berry is the
best yeah yeah oh JJ yeah and that was
during Four Horsemen days the best wow
man we've how much fun must that have
been you got and we all ride in the same
car yeah yeah what kind of car would you
get
um we're all driving Cadillacs and I
bought then all of a sudden the Mercedes
thing hit and I bought
but that started by a Mercedes I never
changed I bought a world of voice one
time but it it just it ain't worth it
yeah because there was a big deal and
you can't park it near anything because
you're afraid it's going to get dinged
up yeah that's what I never liked I rode
with a friend one time who was rich and
and I'm like dude we got to park seven
miles away because you don't want to get
the doors down yeah
um yeah you guys would hit the road huh
oh yeah every well we well there's no
later on we traveled via private jet our
company bought a falcon 10 which was
great but in our younger days we
traveled uh yeah but we we we later
travel during the day you're never gonna
go why go why drive it when I was young
we drove at night but as we started to
realize that we were at a level of
popularity why not spend the night
and going out and enjoy the local you
know whatever food whatever
establishment ladies or flavor yeah yeah
and then travel the next day but then
when we got the jet that's when we [__]
we
like Vegas
worked Seattle back to Vegas all night
yeah Portland back to Vegas on all night
La back to Vegas out all night San Diego
back to Vegas all night it's called the
Great American match on tour Albuquerque
back to Vegas right yeah Vegas Vegas and
then Frisco in L.A and then we hit
Kansas City anyway home
man I mean I was running a weeder
product you know a lot of guys were
blowing up which which is not uncommon I
just doing coke yeah the only reason I
didn't in my dad was a doctor and he
just said don't do it on day one man he
said you're gonna
this guy can see this happening in your
business I don't know anything about it
but you know it happens not not just to
you guys but because it was wear and
tear and travel oh yeah it's almost a
necessity yeah but I avoided that but oh
man I tell you I've I've had 17 nervous
breakdowns
no [__] I was just so exhausted
and one night I I wrestled for an hour
in Orlando or in the old Eddie Graham
Sports Arena which is a tin building 104
degrees and I wrestled Butchery
when my heart was like racing like hell
song I called my dad on a pay phone
and he was in Minneapolis I said dad my
heart's racing
he said what was the last time you went
to bed
and I said I don't know I thought to
myself I didn't want to answer because I
said well I went to bed last night at
what time
so that I never went to bed right and
then
so I had to go I had to go to
um Tokyo the next day
and I got in a plane going God I can't
do this
so I drank all the way to Narita drank
14 hours
my baby slept two hours but I woke up
kept drinking right
this is like 83 or 84.
Landon Narita back then we had the paper
ticket and I said I just can't do this
and I could hear Bob's wife flare son
you know
I walked over to the guy I said when's
the next flight back in the United
States
he said we got one for Seattle leaving
in 20 minutes
I said that when back they didn't have
that deal but the bags took the paper
ticket we'll be back I flew up from
Narita to Seattle Seattle to Chicago
Chicago to Charlotte
and to make a long story short
I sat down next to this guy
I sat down where sat down next to this
guy on the plane
going back and Rita to Seattle
and they go do you mind if I talk to you
he said no why
I said I'm having a nervous breakdown I
need someone to talk to him
and he he said really I said yep I'm
having a nursery account
and um
so we talked all the way to say I'll
drink all the way to Seattle
and then I slept to Chicago
and I walked and got another plane I
landed in Charlotte
and the firm order was there Jimmy
Crockett he said you got to go back
you're advertised
we got back on the plane never even left
the airport went all the way back to
Tokyo oh my God drinking again
I mean that I would I was having a
full-fledged nose breakdown he got there
and went to the arena wrestled an hour
and I broke the sweat and holding it
just started over again but the guy from
Seattle we changed addresses right
he sent me a Christmas card for 10 years
he said I didn't know how famous it were
really enjoyed talking to you man you're
an interesting guy
isn't that crazy I didn't know how
famous you were when I made really
enjoyed talking I hope you're feeling
better
that's a whole pledge breakdown man God
what did it feel like when you're having
a nervous breakdown like what like what
do you kind of go through I had one a
few years ago oh you just you lose
control of me you just like you you'll
be looking for someone to talk to it's
strange it's hard to walk up to someone
and say hey I think I'm having another
breakdown most people want to run away
don't forget to call the cops
he's a wacko
yeah call God no I waited in the plane
took off before I sent it to him yeah I
don't want him calling him
you're like hey remind me when we take
off I got something to do yeah and
nowadays you can imagine walking up to a
plate in it will you talk to me I have
another breakdown okay yeah they'll call
you racist and they land the plane
please and they put you in the suit and
take you off the floor
oh I got about five of them no kidding
yeah it's heavy huh you know
agoraphobias where you have to be close
to something oh yeah yeah no drama
agoraphobia yeah you can't be alone you
can't walk outside of your house oh you
have that you think annoy at it wow yeah
I had it for about six months
I couldn't I couldn't get myself to
leave and drive to the airport
I mean it's horrible what do you think
brought it on and when you feel back in
it like would it because I was just
living a crazy lifestyle
do you think you felt bad about anything
or do you think you just it was just so
much like drinking and partying oh just
so much drinking a party and I just I
didn't sleep yeah and the one thing I
did do which is kind of legendary in our
business
is regardless of what I did to myself
I worked out every day and sometimes I
just push myself too hard and that would
cause that and then
you know having different promoters try
to
you know you know like when I cut my
hair I really lost my mind when I cut my
hair Jim heard
Spartacus put a hearing on I'm Ric Flair
[__]
you know there's something you know when
I cut my hair and I walked through the
Charlotte Airport nobody knew who I was
I wanted to absolutely walk in the
bathroom and kill myself
he used to abnormally walk around or hey
Rick yeah combing my hair and all that
and I got the surfer Joe Eric I'd just
give me a break
uh you know I mean Native Americans it
was a big thing to them to have their
hair they took each other's hair yeah
captured one another they would scalp
one another I started a trend with it
yeah and then they have some for more I
mean I still can't believe I gave into
them yeah
man it's funny because I've cut my hair
before and it [__] hurt me oh I can
remember the girl name Mary Riley she
said are you sure you want to do this
I said no I don't want to do it but I
almost have to keep my job
but man I was I was in shock at that
alone
was it what was a nervous breakdown
how hard was it to be
like I could imagine like I don't have
any children yet I would like to have
some one day you know and that's the
greatest reward in the world was it
really the greatest reward in the world
yes were you surprised that it was so
rewarding did you think did you you know
my problem is I it was the greatest
thing in the world but I didn't have
time to spend with my older ones yeah my
younger ones had more time to spend with
but the younger ones I mean I they lived
in Minneapolis number one
um
and the NWA did not was not that was AWA
so it ended up we didn't even go to
Minneapolis Oh so I only got to see them
during the summer and when they came for
the summer I'm traveling right so I just
had them travel with me
with some of that fun sometimes yeah
when we came to Florida for a week yeah
or we went to Portland for a week or had
went to Dallas for a week you know but a
lot to do here with the kids you know
Busch Gardens yeah I've been to Disney
World and
and uh
Universal at least 50 times each one
yeah with both four sets of kids with my
for the four kids
um is it hard like because you're a hero
to sew like you're a icon to people
you're a hero you're this you know this
thing that's larger than life especially
in the time when you were like when you
were wrestling in your Prime and that
was just the prime for like if somebody
was a star then there was no way to the
the only they were if television and
their job labeled them a star they were
a star there was no and there were there
weren't that many stars right there were
some but there weren't a ton yeah but
was it like I wonder if if it would be
hard as a child right if I'm looking at
my father if I would always feel like
man how do I
love my dad as much as these other
people love him does that make any sense
yeah
yeah I think my my older kids actually
because they didn't understand what I
was doing
I think they were very resentful for a
while
but it you know it just
where is he you know that and all that's
all they want
all that wants your time and the time is
what you don't have yeah
in my my line of work because we travel
I mean even the kids today are still
traveling four days a week oh what's
fascinating a lot of people don't know
about wrestlers is that they there's all
the times they aren't on television
they're still wrestling oh yeah
different fights out they're still
wrestling different men they're leaving
they're leaving for a two-week tour of
uh England and Italy yeah uh leaving now
when next week
yeah I just wonder if that built up like
what it would be like to
and you didn't have a choice so you
couldn't wrestle less really right
um no I'm kidding I had a chance to make
a movie with Orion pictures
they wanted me to do a James Bond things
I think what I hear was like that's best
the guy was a big fan of money he came
to
The Forum was we're wrestling out there
but they offered me 250 Grand wow and I
went back and then cracked and said yeah
you have to drop the world championship
and go for six months but I don't know
where you'll be when you get back and I
couldn't they have been buffaloed I
should have gone and made the movie you
think I'm back and I would have got
raped sure I would have gave you but you
know you know it's completely you don't
know and you I think life forced you to
make a decision based on what you know
not what you think you
yeah and be this I mean a lot of guys
tried forever to make in Hollywood
and three have made it yeah Batista made
it John made it and of course Dwayne
but but I can tell you I'm in a Roddy
Piper spent his whole life
but outside of that they live there were
just B movies yeah he never got that
crack and it's not good to have a talent
he just
it's not very political too it's so
political yeah and now it's a lot of
people's you know there's also even
nepotism in that business there wasn't
there was nepotism in you guys business
kind of isn't there or like I guess
there's a tradition of name in you
guys's business you know because you
have like Dusty roads dust and Roads you
had the Von eriks you had
um there's a lot of people whose
children will also flares the flares
yeah your daughter is a wrestler yes
both your YouTube but your sons wrestled
huh well your youngest son wrestled your
oldest son didn't wrestle my all of a
sudden they did wrestle yeah yeah
my younger son's the one who passed away
yeah yeah you you have been great
yeah but my daughter I have no problem
saying this it's the best wrestler
period female or male in the business
today yeah and she's badass yeah
was there ever a thought uh uh did they
you guys ever get pitched to do a match
against each other no no no yeah
what was it like when they had the
ladies of wrestling back then because
remember that horrible they put those
Danes in there sometimes you know and
everybody looked like they were like
Angry Jazzercise yeah yeah no that it
didn't float it was it was a nice Theory
and concept but
did y'all to travel with those ladies no
no you never saw them I saw lady
wrestlers in the old days but it's a
totally different thing and it and they
were badly managed and mistreated as the
images were I mean the midgets got paid
nothing really that's terrible yeah
that's why
anything I could do to help them
Transportation wise and that or buy them
drinks and food or that or get them laid
get them a little yeah yeah
all right
shut up Lane
and would he wear a cowboy hat yeah oh
yeah Google
Cowboy Lane
he's famous and was he the tallest I
think I think he's only 410 right
that's tall enough to [__] huh
Geo would you like him take a cowboy
yeah he's a little pretty small
dang you got nice hair on him huh yeah
the guy with Hollywood 4 10 4 11.
four foot yeah yeah
oh if you show up to [__] at four foot
you got to really mean it yeah yeah
especially with a five foot nine chick
oh wow how do you even I mean I don't
even
God I would have watched that man yeah
like scale of the mountain I'm gonna
watch that match dude or at least like
hanging up your uh putting the star on
the Christmas tree on yeah I have a
friend that was with a one-legged [__]
and uh Des Moines Iowa one day I said
how was that because
it was brutal
we had a little person in our town and
people would always try and get him to
like tell him like that people always
study new secrets and like magic and
[__] people always like do some [__]
Magic
say [__] like that
um who tell me about this say you're on
a plane right the plane's full of
cocaine right it's going down you don't
do cocaine but there's you gotta there's
you there's one and it's all wrestlers
who's the guy that's got to get in there
and [__] the only way to save the
plane is somebody's got to do all the
cocaine who's the guy that could really
[__] party I used to do a lot of
cocaine
oh the I used to call him John Wesley
Hardin you know with John Wesley artist
supposedly the fastest Gunslinger of all
time
I've never seen anybody in my life and
and this is a compliment yeah to him as
a person a man
I've never seen anybody that could run
and I'll take Keith Richards all day
long then run with Roddy Piper wow the
hot rod brother he used to wear that
shirt that said we had the best shirt of
all time how much Rod can you take
I said that's just my gimmick I want
that damn shirt all right
how much ride can you dig God boy I
would want that yeah I'd love dude my
God
I would love I mean I would turn the
eight ball into a two ball in four
minutes yeah you have no idea really
right
I wrote my book He said
he's like
the Dominican Republic wrestling Jack
bonano we had a riot after the billions
of the matches
oh
yeah Jacksonville because over there the
wrestling's name listen I'm the first
white guy to go to the islands man this
was rough no [__] what didn't they like
well we did a finish where he had a
sleeper what was his finish hole right
it's not a little guy right and the
referee one dropped my arm right to
right and the bell rang right and they
thought that he won and the guy went to
hand the belt to me I'm laying there
like well brought in all that and they
thought what the [__] and they hit the
ring wow caught ourselves all the way
back
got back there
I'm glad they took in the office they
gave me five grand and gave Roddy Pipers
platoon full of cocaine it took us over
to a whorehouse and dropped us off and
drop you off
oh he Riley looked like Chevy Chase and
uh Trading Places and lying around his
mouth
but that trading Place does that movie
with Chevy Chase
Scarface got nothing on all right wow
man he ended up doing stand-up comedy at
the end of his career yeah he listen the
most entertaining guy oh he Demi he's
funnier than uh I used when I inducted
him an Hall of Fame
I said uh who's the guy that was
murdered General McCarthy for a while oh
uh Jim Carrey yeah Jim Carrey yeah he he
funny Jim Carrey wow yeah he was
incredibly funny witty
yeah what was the gimmick that a lot of
gimmicks you know I mean one thing about
wrestling is staying creative staying
unique especially like
um as inner as the wrestlers themselves
but also as the producers the people
putting it on what was some gimmicks or
a gimmick that [__] flopped you were
like this is [__] unreal
too numerous too many to pick on just
one yeah
it's here's the deal they
it would they have probably have a
hundred kids I'm not accurate on this
count but between 80 and 100 kids in
Orlando right now at NXT right
um if I'm looking at what I've seen in
the last 10 years which my daughter's
involved in that equation
in the last 10 years
my daughter
Sasha
Bailey
Becky
Roman
Seth
Dean
they're all Main eventers and still are
yeah that's hard
and then once you get on top it's harder
to stay on top
because you don't know Mrs has been
around Miss has been there 20 years yeah
believe it or not Randy Orton's been
there 22 years he's just 40 years old
wow you know what I mean yeah and
Randy's still on top Randy's started on
top and then on top
Cena had 20 years on top it's hard
it's important but the percentage of
people that come out of there I would
say is one percent
um it's that hard I went to a big
recruiting thing this summer in La at
WrestleMania and they had a hundred kids
I think
intent they took 10.
and they and they recruit legit college
athletes from all over the country to
attend flew them in put them through the
drills and you know physical drills
um not the kind like we used to but
still to see what they're made of but
most division one athletes are
you know I've got to fortitude and that
and out of that 10 one might make it
it's sad is that her yeah was there as
many people trying when you were coming
up no it was what the young where do
they did everything in the world to keep
young guys
away from it yeah wow so why why was
that why because they didn't want the
competition
so a young man the best example of all
time was Ricky Steamboat
with you know not not only a great
wrestler great person but when Steamboat
came to Charlotte
wait if they hated him he's handsome
young great body because that was back
then the bodies were just starting to
become
a big part of the of of the business
especially in Vince's business
and you know you want everybody wasn't
lifting weights and nobody was as
handsome yeah what about Personalities
in a way yeah I had I had to really
fight for him to get him
to even get them going because they said
uh he'll never make it well look how big
he got
so hmm
yes I guess it was it is a real nice kid
too which is not the kind of guy that's
going to be a prick you know right
it's easy to be a prick and then say
that's your way out
I mean the [__] I want to do this I
don't want to do this anyway [__] you
guys like I can name 100 guys like that
yeah I don't want to do this anyway or
you held me back that's the greatest
land how do you hold someone back
if you're not the promoter how do you
hold someone back
yeah you call her promoter and say this
guy's an [__]
well a good promoter's gonna go [__] you
guys got talent
if he can draw money we're like Vince
look at all the [__] with Bishop he's
still found a way to use them
right right and it worked but how do you
leave the company
in the garbage truck
I mean he always gets it then
put him in a garbage truck and throw
them up his last day of the government
really yeah
wow yeah but he he utilizer to make
money yeah Vince could forgive anything
if there's a dollar attached to it he's
a businessman businessman be a business
first
wow hey come on you're gonna be the Hulk
right so that's called
so Bischoff Hulk Kevin Nash and Scott
Hall would go out on TV
this is Hulk and I used to think to
myself what in the Hulk knows this I
used to go man this just ain't cool
Bishop we got so mad at me because I
wouldn't do it and they'd be on TV and
say we're going to close you down Vince
we're sitting here telling you because
they beat him for 83 weeks right oh beat
him in the ratings yeah for 83 weeks
right and then Along Came Stone Cold
Steve Austin and then one day he went
like this to Vince and guess what 83
weeks are over wow and within two years
the company was bankrupt yeah but he's
forgiven Hulk
and he forgave Kevin's got all McMahon
did sure yeah you brought them all back
yeah and he was always to make money
yeah I mean Hulk Hogan and he oh to me
Hulk Hogan is the biggest star he in
Austin
are there two biggest stars in the
history of the business
okay tell you a great story I'm the NWA
world champion I'm traveling around the
world
doing everything
Hulk is in WWF right I go home
Minneapolis my dad goes how's it going
right now how's everything going I said
it's good he said all my friends are
Hulk Hogan They Don't Know Who You Are
oh dead I'm the [__] world champion
of what a what
hate you [__] Hogan
I'll say this your championship belt I
don't know if win win
no I'm gonna tell the story about the
hooter girls in Jacksonville when I hit
my watch and I couldn't find it
or my main
yeah
subject almost a professor at
Northwestern University I took her back
to the hotel in Chicago and my friend
came in at four o'clock in the morning
and she was going around revolving doors
my Rolex
they've all got a story yet
you threw your Rolex in a bowl of
spaghetti and then told you I'd love
them
I said we're gonna throw my walls oh we
don't do that I'm frequently in Oregon
and round two get the [__] out of here
do you think people dreaded scene were
you always like too much of a party for
the scene no no people love me people
love me yeah
yeah
I could find something to do in Lubbock
Texas on a Sunday night brother oh yeah
man that's a lot that's hard to do yeah
somewhere somewhere there's a victim
I just need to start the conversation
and what was this
who else could drink like that with you
who could really oh God name it that's
that endless double A Mike eggstrand
Piper a drinking either there's a lot of
guys can really drink yeah
did you ever try to stop drinking well I
guess after your cert after your after
that well I didn't drink for a year you
didn't drink for a year and then one
time I was taking steroids and I took an
overdose of one and my heart went like
this and the guy said uh
you've been drinking too much you
thought I had cardiomyopathy so I did an
old duelistly or
that's hard for me to quit drinking it
was hard it brought me a rehab I had no
problem quit drinking
what did you how long were you in rehab
for 35 days and you where'd you go to
place your own Tampa oh that's nice yeah
Florida has Fuller every every other
building in Florida yeah this is a dump
it was It was a
an old uh
um
no not a Days Inn but La Quinta oh yeah
oh yeah over here on follower right yeah
so my roommate my roommate's a doctor
from Fort Lauderdale that's there for
digesting
uh uh crystal meth anally oh that's one
roommate now what's that got to do with
me drinking the other one the other one
is the other guy is the 23 year old that
was taken 40 milligrams of Valium
at 23. you don't think he would vibrate
in the other guy
I'm trying to think
um
the other guy I don't know what the hell
he did but I mean it was so far-fetched
and here's the deal I get there I go
through all the physical and all that
get all the [__] done right the doctor
checks me out I wake up in the morning
and I when I was a kid I used to smoke
so I I just loaded up with cigarettes
dip I've always dipped my whole life
I've quit playing and I don't dip
anymore but I you will again though I
might well but it's just nasty it's
different you know oh yeah I don't like
it but I didn't do it yeah but um I look
across the courtyard I'm smoking a
marble right and I'm bringing a cup of
coffee and I said I said to the guy my
roommate I can't remember his name
just like a doctor he said as a doctor
I said what you doing here it's been a
patient here for five years I said the
doctor is taking care of us and the
[__] patient
what I couldn't believe it so I walked
into the counselor is that [__] guy
does he have a license no they're
pulling well how was it how is he
practicing medicine
it is a nun house I was in the [__]
night house
I I mean I cried I went this is another
house I'm full of nuts
when the doctor is taking care of you
give me a shot prescribing medication
and he's there for he's a five-year vet
and he's a patient and he's a patient
and he's taking care of me
oh my God who wrote that script I don't
know that's what I said to him holy [__]
wow oh my God damn right you're not
allowed talking to the girls Rick okay
I didn't want you to take the test again
what does this look like a bear or a
skunk or an owl it looks like you dumb
[__] why are you asking me the same
question when looking at this box for
three days three weeks and I'm not gonna
change I don't know what it looks like
what does it look like to you
and why are you in here
too yeah you think I'm lying
no [__] and did y'all do any Athletics
in there did y'all do like volleyball
you know one guy told me I missed the
morning walk and we went to the big
meeting I threatened to kill him I said
next time you stooge on me a
[__] I'll find you before we get
here
cut away everything anybody want to talk
to Sir oh the circle before you go to
bed
God circled jerk
God man no no [__] it was brutal see you
never say you never thought coin is over
so broad to give you the coin to do it I
walked across the street I'm like
walking into a bar put on the counter I
said I mean you can have this you can
frame it say Ric Flair was there and
give me six Miller lights and two Jack
and Coke and two uh Kettle One and
cranberry and lime I'm like Frank I'm
all right there then uh then I had a
limo pick me up and take me over to the
beach yeah yeah oh you got to go for a
swim after that oh Jesus I wasn't
kidding what was was there ever any like
wow you're not supposed to drink
okay
oh wow they faked me out with that for a
while the company will never have your
back break if you don't go back and
rehabit you said you'd go back I'm not
going back yeah well company number
usually gonna say okay fine two weeks
later you come over to TV yeah of course
I thought I wasn't allowed to come
anymore you are
hahaha
do you think there was anything was
there a point where you really damaged
your ability to go back do you think
that you damaged it not that they chose
it
no with them no I always got along with
them yeah
no that's that that's one of the reasons
I'm successful I always I've always said
yes
it's the difference between me and Hulk
and he'll tell you I said yes Hulk said
no yeah
because I wanted to get along I didn't
give a [__] right if they gave me
something to do I just made it better
I'll do whatever they put me in that
house act like I'm not okay I am a nut
did alcohol your son your your son uh
had addiction issues I I'm in recovery
right so I've had addiction issues over
the years it's in my family yeah with
heroins
it's not an addiction disease yeah it's
unbelievable I've never
it's I I was in such a denial
unbelievable and as a parent is it hard
to notice when that's going on because I
never been a parent like is it hard to
notice like
I think I noticed a little bit when high
school with the weed now but here's the
thing he was on life support four times
okay just be prior to dying and one time
one time when he came off the ventilator
his left leg was like gone yeah I mean
we had to send him the two and that's a
Sierra Tucson and from there to he went
to Colorado I mean
to climb um
to this facility that exercised to get
his leg back and all that oh his legs
shut down that's like any money that not
shut down totally but he it was a good
women Yeah Yeah Eddie Money used to Huff
so much gas and his legs shut down yeah
well then the next time
the worst was his oxygen level went down
to 42 for 24 hours that's supposed to be
in like 95 plus 97 actually 98. the
thing I put on your finger right his
doctor calls me in and says if he wakes
up he's gonna be brain dead
um so I was just I'm I'm preparing you
I swear to God is I'm sitting here in
front of you he woke up
the whole family was there
we thought it was you know we all came
everybody came from around the country
it's a good because we thought he was
gonna die right there he woke up he was
completely [__] normal wow nothing
wrong did it shock you guys
the doctor looked at me it shocked him
he sat down I've never seen anything
like this in my life I'm happy for you
and I'm sorry that I gave you that
diagnosis no I'm glad you did
because then we went and sat down and
figured out Auto attack it again
well this is after the leg thing
man he was a fighter huh yeah but I mean
to this day when you go to the doctor
and you have a if you if your auction is
at 42 you're you're not supposed to be
functioning yeah you can't even whistle
dude yeah and he woke up he was
completely fine
he's a tough kid and I went I went my
God this has got to be you know like
this will be the wake-up call yeah and
so I took him to Tokyo
and I got I got him playing and go back
I looked up and said let me tell you
they put Paul McCartney in jail here for
smoking and Joint
they will bury you because it's very
strict in Tokyo they don't [__] around
like they do here
with with drugs you're in drugs in Tokyo
or Singapore or something like that yeah
in a world of [__]
man he came back home to go to
WrestleMania to see his daughter see my
daughter
and
let him on my site
wanted to buy tennis shoes
came back
went to the went through Del Frisco's to
watch NCAA he wasn't drinking or
anything
bottle of pills filled with water
um
so Wendy picks up the pills took it away
didn't even tell him I had it right
so
he wants to go back to the hotel I'll go
go ahead it's a Wendy went with him so
when he called me and says can I knock
on read the door
to get um
um
like aspirin or not Tylenol or something
like that right she had a headache and
um
he didn't answer the door so I went
right back right this is what this is
like all in 45 minutes time right right
yeah you're at Del Frisco's you hear
that you head back I open the door
he's like this
just sitting in a chair no sit on the
floor okay so I didn't see any needles
so I thought oh God he just I've seen
him like this a thousand times
so I said do I call the police the same
thing at the same thing
I said no I'll just I'm gonna put him in
bed that but because we were so lucky he
didn't make a news because the cops
kept it loaded on the DL for me they put
them in rooms and under a different name
and
yeah they're understanding yes great
guys they pulled them out of his car one
time and called me I mean
so I had to do a really great Report
with them so
I just said I said but this time I said
I'm gonna let them bottom out I mean
that's they keep that word bottom out
you know yeah I just couldn't imagine
him dying in an alley somewhere because
I let him bottom out right I mean how
would I ever get over that it's really
hard so I wake up in the morning I go
out coffee with my oldest daughter
come back and I just said [__] I'm so
[__] mad at him right now I'm not
gonna I opened the [__] door just to
check on them which I just I even walked
out halfway said [__] I'm just gonna
check on them my candles leave them
walking he was purple [__] call the cops
same two same crew same exact people
same paramedics
boom
and the guy said he would say the same
thing to tell them we'll stand outside
he came out
three minutes and said he didn't make it
oh I said what
he said he didn't make this time work
man
oh I've told this story a hundred times
but I can't it still kills me
I started drinking from 10 in the
morning until I got there at 9 30. got
into the bartenders while they were
setting up
9 30 in the morning till 2 A.M for five
[__] years
I just go ahead just
I just couldn't believe it
say if you don't go drink right then
what what why do you think you had to go
like just I don't the only way to get
away from it
I didn't take drugs
how do you get away from the feeling
that you're the juror yeah responsible
for not calling
hmm I should have called
it's hard if we it's I'm sure it's
really hard to be the parent of someone
that has you know an addiction what did
you learn about addiction like watching
your son
like did you was there anything that you
were able to learn about like watching
it from you know
yeah don't be in denial
um I I'm worse than French letter
Fritz was a non-nile of the boys
he would not believe that they were
getting high
that they were screwed up all the time
he was in denial
oh it's just you guys are just imagining
her carried Through The discus 210 feet
at Houston I mean it he would you know
that big deep voice yeah the boys are
fine they're just growing up and having
a little fun smoking a little weed like
they were a lot more than that
but
do you think addiction just runs in
y'all's family well I don't know your
other children do they suffer from no no
no yeah
I don't know how he got it
I mean it's heartbreaking witness I've
lost a lot of friends with from
addiction and it is heartbreaking to
watch you know so I can only imagine
what it's like what was your son like
like what kind of what kind of guy was
he the greatest kid in the world
fun handsome
bum
I mean I know I'm talking about somebody
who's a he was a lady killer man
yeah I live he lived with me for a while
whoever after I got divorced the last
time and he he would he would call me
and say Dad will you do me a favor and I
said what's happened we talked to this
girl's friend while I'm uh God we run a
wingman for me yeah we are yeah he used
to bring his life and come get her out
I'll watch TV but get get the friend out
of here I can't even have a conversation
with her
if you can find humor in this as I'm
standing up there
let's say they're 1500 people at the
funeral maybe two thousand
a huge Church in Charlotte whatever hell
and there were 20 girls in their first
two rows I didn't know
wow
man
I would take him down in South Carolina
to Columbia to go to the Gamecock game
huh I said well I'm leaving tomorrow
morning 10 o'clock
you come home with a different girl
drive home the next day every day
like father like son he was the master
man yeah yeah and it's Jesus
do you think he felt like it was tough
to live I mean I just wonder what it's
like if your dad is so
such a he has had such a unique life you
know do you I wonder if you feel
competitive do you feel or it's just
life that's just life I I think I say it
just like because the other kids aren't
affected like that at all yeah
I actually actually
I can imagine maybe once in a life
smoked a cigarette when she was
10 years old or two I don't mean nothing
nothing and she's around it a lot I mean
it's not as prevalent as it was which is
a big difference thank God what drugs
harness prevalent now no there is
problem but not where the guys can just
grab me they're more aware yeah for some
reason thank God everybody's aware of
the fact
that
the [__] is dangerous yes and we didn't
have time to think about back then yeah
the guys and if it made you look bigger
it kept you up longer but at least they
have three days off we didn't have days
off [__]
the Hulk was on I it wasn't just me Hulk
without 72 days at a time wow it's a
long time to be away from home oh I
can't imagine yeah you come on people
look different yeah they invented cell
phone so your goddamn wife would call
you
Jesus
but that that song of Kid Rock you know
and uh
living alive in a slow head yeah
different girl every night at the hotel
yeah
here's to call the front desk and say if
anybody calls to me I ain't here
hey my friend I am an alien
my friend let us ask for Tony Atlas
there's a comedian there's a comedian
named Larry Reeb yeah he used to have
this joke one of my favorite jokes he
said my wife said never answer the phone
during sex I said what if it's you
calling
I always love that one man did any just
strange women ever show back up at your
house so that had a freaking scary are
you kidding me to throw up the driveway
I have no idea who you are what do you
mean you promised me last night I didn't
you promise you [__] now I'm hurting my
kids
my wife's in the front yard
never admit you're wrong what happened
nothing
I found black hair in the carpet in here
I said what are you talking about it's
on the dog I am donating a dog over here
this is human hair
who'd you have here nobody somebody had
a dog with 11 inch hair over here
like I think it was a long-haired Chow
yeah yeah what are we gonna do you know
oh my way I'll have you I'll call them
please you told me before you loved me
what are you talking about I didn't know
your name
you lied
maybe I did what
what about the product man so this is
new
Ric Flair I like it man makes me feel
good it does it'd be great enough
well you did I'm almost done
I can leave it in a camper on too dude
all of another can Dude hell yeah it
almost makes you feel erect a little
wow oh
what's the toughest thing about getting
older right
by getting older yeah what's been like
one one thing that surprised you that
you didn't think would be that certain
way or something that's been kind of
interesting you know it's interesting
for me my my dad was 70 when I was born
so it's all like even just getting to
sit around a man who's 70. right and
being the president it's just you know
it's almost like um I don't know it's
just interesting for me you know I never
got to spend a bunch of time talking
with my dad and stuff so even to be able
to have a conversation as an adult yeah
the guy in his 70s kind of like
resonates with me in like a special
place I think
um what's yeah what's been interesting
about just being older like what's or
what's been surprising about getting
older what what do you think would not
be one way or maybe would be different
or
um
no I don't know I don't think I even
ever thought about
anything like that until I got sick then
you really appreciate
you appreciate it when you recover from
something like that I mean the airplane
crash was one thing
getting that with lightning with
something else but when you literally on
life support and you almost die yeah
and then you realize that for some
reason
you're lucky enough to be
and I truly believe that he makes every
decision
he is going to give you another shot
I spend so much time
preoccupied with trying to figure out
how not to [__] up really yeah because I
love to [__] up
yeah I mean I'd love to have fun I don't
mean I don't mean [__] up right I don't
want to hurt anybody right but how do I
how do I have fun and not get in trouble
well it's just it because social media
you can't do anything
yeah and I love to go out and I like I
never drink at my house there's not a
one drop of alcohol miles I'm a social
drinker
that's purely me yeah so and I just go
out every night
you know people understand when you do
when you you spend 38 years on the road
like Kevin Nash said in one time if I
don't spend two nights in a hotel every
week
I'm lost
when I took that ear off and Bishop off
and sued me yeah and I went home I
hadn't been home
I hadn't been home and didn't even know
my wife Christ my mother-in-law lived
there now we had two Maids I didn't even
know it
what Advanced days I'm breaking yeah
three o'clock at the Country Club
sometimes one wow what do you do to the
country club I'm not playing cards I'm
drinking yeah
and talking to the bartender she's a
nice looking wow
I'm playing poker with my liver that's
what I'm playing it's pasta night send
the kids up
dude I remember my dad used to take us
to the bar and they'd have like that
bowl of [__] peanuts oh I know
[__] man it was so much fun dude and
that's when bars didn't even have TVs in
a remember that
that that I can't deal with
no TV no bar no me these days you gotta
have the tea you want the sports on
I live in diaper sports but you remember
when they didn't I don't know yeah do
you want to know something yeah
I never knew this is the guys I'm so
embarrassed I didn't know what prime
Netflix Hulu I didn't know what that was
until
I get sick I didn't know how to Google
myself yeah I didn't know what Google
was
all I did was Drive travel wrestle
and have fun
I didn't know anything I'm still not
computer literary
she showed me the other day how to work
emojis on my phone oh wow I mean I'm and
then and then when I'm laying in the
chair
home in the hospital I didn't ever be in
a rehab for a month learn how to walk I
didn't know that I had a stoma
one day one day I'm sitting there I'm
home in the house
and uh the girl comes and sat down
I'm here to change your bag
yeah yeah and I go
and I said
I said I didn't well while on rehab
because I couldn't walk or anything oh
and they're there and I had forgotten
I didn't know whether I didn't know had
the stolen in rehab
the whole time you're in rehab yeah I
didn't know it for 31 days
then I got home and the woman's there to
change it
wow yeah that's all for that then you
were out of it then you appreciate life
yeah was it hard to go back to drink
well then were you shocked that you just
after that 30 after the days in rehab
that you went back to drinking is it
scary like is it bad for you to drink if
like is it did the doctor say don't
drink
today I mean also the doctor was in the
facility so or they said don't drink of
course they did okay but here's the deal
yeah so being a former Family Medical
family
I went I didn't get one second opinion I
got 30. okay every time I met a doctor
that knew anything about your your
internal I'd had prior surgeries
in 2015 and it's one in one million
times that you can Nick your intestine
and it can burst again hmm
and that was not one million
so now when I drink my kidney levels
everything's perfect and my my kidney
level off a little bit the doctor tells
me drink more water so now I drink for
every drink I drink a small bottle of
water nice
you got a plan now you got a plan
what do you think God put you on Earth
for do you think about that sometimes it
seems like you do
um
I don't know but I'm sure trying to Min
my ways
I'm a wild I was a wild silver
I still am I'm harmless but I was oh
it's harmless but wow
I've been new to the toys
with nurses that did not sign a waiver I
wonder how many run around on them
what wrestler had that real hammer on
him in no homo but where wrestler really
had that freaking wand on him huh
you know I don't remember somebody had
to have that launcher
um
I mean you've been around some of the
biggest men in the world
yeah I know I'm trying to think
what about Haystack baby oh I only knew
he's that dog no
he might have had that needle on him
yeah I got the name but I don't want to
put on there yeah no no sweat yeah yeah
I got it
look I'm just glad somebody's got a big
one teased his wife all the time no
yeah when you see one of those joust
victims like his wife that's got to be
unreal yeah but she wouldn't she
wouldn't like me making a joke no I
don't think I don't think we should I'm
not trying to get it out of here the
front page out of the whole interview
Ric Flair says
the hammer I remember but there's
something about you you know because
most of your life you get to know your
own weiner right yeah and then every now
and then somebody walks across with some
real crazy wiener you're like my God
that guy is [__] running a different
ball game
I was in a different line of work it's
different genetic
that guy's in a different line of work
boys any other questions that you had
there's anything the last match I saw
you last match in Nashville yeah oh
that's a dehydrated man
it would have been so good
yeah were you what do you mean you're
dehydrated for it
no I was fixated on weighing 218 ball I
was in better shape then than I was
in 2008 I mean I was up there where I
went right now to John Cena's trainer
500 free squads wow running a mile and I
hate running this is two years ago a
year ago July wow
you're going July and uh I mean I got I
had 10 weeks to get in shape for it and
I was doing everything up I mean and I
had a partner and you know I drove I
dropped so I'm going right now to Rob
John Cena's guy up here at Landa Lakes I
mean and we've uh but I was fixated on
got down to 218.
um but a cosmetic level nightmare anyway
so I was gonna wear a shirt
but I I woke up in the morning of course
I was drinking the night before
at the Palm with the Hilton in Nashville
right I love that bar yeah it's nice and
then I'll saw Bobby you know one night
so um Bobby Rock Kid Rock yeah yeah and
then he came in the match oh yeah he
walked in my dressing room and he went
um
I've been entertaining you for a long
time I want you to I came to watch you
entertain me tonight then we all went to
his place afterwards yeah
yeah they got to get a bathroom on each
floor though man that's a good point man
Jesus Christ buy a [__] bathroom that
five five four climb downstairs to one
stall when they got 2 000 people
oh God it makes me want to get one of
those stoma bags yeah exactly yeah well
no don't wait for that but um anyway
so all I had was two cups of coffee and
three we went I bite I didn't drink any
water or anything oh and I got out there
and I felt great and all that and then I
realized that anxiety and I made the
mistake of saying
to one of the guys I don't feel good of
course now they think
I'm having a heart attack yeah or
I just I don't feel it I got
light-headed I actually
fell asleep on the apron
I'm standing really oh yeah yeah
and the guy had to go Rick Rick when I
woke up and I got back in and then I did
something else and I'm laying there and
at the end
and Manny my son-in-law is going
you uh you have to wake up sir I have to
wake up Sir you're handing me the brass
knucks to hit uh Jared with right
so
he put the rest of my hand
you have to wake up Sir you have to wake
up Sir boom
but you know
I got whacked myself way too early and
then because everybody was panicking
until to end it right I had faked like I
was having a heart attack I went ah just
because I want everybody to slow down
[__] we can do this
I mean I can make it just listen to me
but you know what everybody's first of
all I appreciate they were scared of
death I was gonna die okay
but I wanted the match to be better
because we'd rehearsed it to be a
20-minute unbelievable they're supposed
to suplex free Alpha top rope and all
kinds of [__]
but anyway it that's what makes you want
to do it again because I got in such
good shape and it's like I'm a really go
oriented like now my new goal is like
I'll be 75 right so in February so I
want to bench press
225 five times and I want to do the 500
free squats in 14 minutes again
yeah that's a lot yeah it it it's very
doable but you have to do it
no
no that might be one of the best quotes
I've ever heard right it's very doable
but yeah but you have to do it yeah I
used to be able to do when I was reading
the best shape of my life I used to take
a deck of cards Jokers being 20.
right so flip the card right
10 crunches 10 push-ups 10 free squats
next one Joker 20. wow I could do all
that it's
457 of each
in 38 minutes my record
that's hard
because getting up and down for the free
squats and the push-ups
440 57 push-ups this [__] heart
that's a lot yeah Jesus that's a lot
yeah
that's okay I I couldn't do that for the
last match but I when in my in your
Prime well trying to you know when
you're when you're traveling these [__]
towns right they don't have they don't
even have a YMCA oh yeah some of these
small towns so I just had a hotel room
and had to figure out a way to kill the
day so
there's other you know what I mean
what's who's somebody you miss wrestling
who do I miss wrestling yeah
the biggest thing is while wrestling is
a camaraderie God when you just know who
personally like is there a person you
met you were like man we really it was
just a real
oh I miss iron the most probably
he just lost a son too to addiction or
no
I'm not sure what it was but he
it's a horrible thing yeah
um
I just had my travels from anyone for I
traveled with Sean and Hunter and
I love I love hanging out with
Undertaker and I don't get to see him
very often
love of Steve Austin I hardly get to see
Steve
Steve just um
you know keeps himself and basically
isolation yeah Undertaker came out to a
show mine a week and a half ago two
weeks ago in Austin oh yeah it's really
nice to meet him and Michelle that's his
wife yeah beautiful yeah he's beautiful
it is about adopted a beautiful little
baby oh really yeah oh I didn't know
that yeah yeah they're a great guy they
were so kind yeah he's a great guy that
was cool
um who did was it did you ever get to
meet Madonna
no but Dennis Rodman did yeah Dennis is
my man
how in the hell do you do you cheat on
Madonna
for karma Electra I go I mean Dennis I
said Dennis I didn't she realized that I
would walk on fire to lay on top of that
and you she you caught her I think
Madonna is incredible oh yeah when she
was younger with that song or hers Like
a Virgin like a bird oh Jesus Christ
dance
with your heartbeat
I'll tell you this story Rick so I'm at
my grandparents right dude my girl and
uh they wouldn't let us watch wrestling
or nothing dude because they were
[__] you know they wanted the Lord to
find us and so I would go on the Lord's
day
my
mother-in-law would I said say to my
wife they're they're drinking again out
by the pool and on the Lord's Day
kiss my ass Marianne the Lord's day
every day is the Lord's day especially
in freeloaded living off me
that's the bottom line free loader
and a large day
shut up mama
shouldn't be yeah oh God
that would make a guy drink oh yeah that
probably started it Jesus Christ
we have to pack the beer cans up me and
iron right to tell stories laugh all day
long
laughs
I went across the street I met my
grandparents so I'll go across street
there's nothing to do they live in they
were in a small town in Illinois and
Wyoming Illinois so I'll go across the
street and there's a park there yeah and
some girl I never known or anything she
had a TR like a transistor radio she
plugged it in and tuned it to Like a
Virgin right yeah she's that starts
dancing on this picnic table for me and
I never met her or anything I'm just
like I'm like probably nine or ten I
walked into the Park yeah I was just
wondering what big stars came out to see
you got like what like I was trying to
think of some of the big stars then
that were like some of the biggest in
the world and who you would have crossed
paths with that would have been
surprising
uh not that many I mean
I'll tell you I I I Adore Chris Everett
right yeah so I'm flying to Japan
and I'm sitting this far from Chris
Evert she's wearing a yellow
polo shirt right gold Rolex
this is in the 80s smoking hot right God
and I mean and uh
not a word
yeah you know I'm not gonna go over and
shoot myself and die right and she
didn't give you a sign nothing zero zero
but I flew back with Yvonne Lindell and
he wouldn't stop talking oh God Jesus
Christ
Yvonne get a drink calm down
yes wrestling's fake okay now
[__] can we move forward
I live next door to Vince McMahon good
for you buddy dude I sat next to Eddie
Money one time yeah he he told me he was
used to Huff gas right and so one of his
legs shut down and get it working and
then he started showing me semi-nude
pictures of his newest wife oh God it's
pretty cool yeah
well no she she is like uh
wow you gotta respect it you know
what if I want to show you this Rick so
I have an alternate personality it's a
wrestler right and it's called Uh the
Rat King baby so I just want to show you
one of my promos let me know what you
think okay
and this isn't you Rick this is a
different guy yeah what are your
thoughts on that raccoon
then the regular people who run you out
your little loose meat dinners
well I got news for you
what kind of news he is saying anyone
can get it will you be the one Rat King
all you need to know Rick is that I'm
ready cause I'm gonna give you the truth
baby and I'm gonna give you the trauma
name the time and the place and the
place and the time cause I got a clock
and a globe and an ax to grind
from Alaska to Nebraska from Maine to
Fort Wayne
it's your call you Turkish slice and
boner monkey
what do you think there potential
I'll take it man you look good from a
legend I'll take it rick thanks so much
for sharing your life thank you man
you've been uh it's obvious you wanted
to be an Entertainer and you've been
extremely entertaining throughout my
entire life thank you very much
appreciate it yep
you guys have a great trip
you reminded me my own give me
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take